i can i can see your faces
i see you we're standing there
isn't it weird though and it's it's so
strange to be in a large group i mean we
haven't been we've hardly been out
you know in the uk so it's amazing how
much fun was it tonight to be i mean
y'all look like you were partying first
of all it looked like so much fun in
there you know for
for three out of our four actors to win
and the fact that gene smart won for
hacks as well i mean
it's just it just feels amazing it
really does feel amazing and i just feel
so proud of everybody and proud of our
show and the crew and the cast and
everyone this was a special role though
because you got to play a really gritty
character a woman who had some juice but
also a lot of grit and a lot of problems
i never knew if i liked her from
episodes there were moments
i loved her we battled i loved her we
battled yeah but you see that's that but
that's life you know that's what i loved
about her so much was that nobody's
perfect you know she's a mother who just
and a grandmother who has no choice but
just to keep on going and sometimes when
the chips are down that's all you can do
as a parent you just have to keep going
and that's that's what i loved the most
about our show is that we didn't shy
away from
those harsh realities that that that is
most people's lives um and it really it
felt very special to play her i know it
said limited series but that's what i
was just like can we do this again
can you do this again we need more money
can you do it again there's questions
that need to be answered there's cases
that need to be solved i know i mean
does she stay with richard or not what
happens um
you know there are
there are the truth is i don't know
honestly i don't know there are
conversations
there are lots of ideas floating around
but i think until there's a script that
we can all look at and take a view of
you know is it another story worth
telling or not um
then i just we don't know i don't know
if they get the script would you
i thought you know it would be a lot to
consider because it honestly was so hard
like it took something
of me
that that yeah i had to take this year
off did a little therapy like it truly
i've taken a minute to put myself back
together so um so i'd have to really
think that through
because sometimes you do have to look
after your own mental health and you
know things like that well you had to go
to some super dark places for there i
mean and i can only imagine it's hard to
shake those at the end of the day and
sometimes you just don't i've had so
many actors say you don't shake it it
sticks with you yeah i mean you don't
there's it always leaves a little nick
on your soul somewhere and that
definitely happened with mayor and just
trying to get her to kind of quieten
down in my system has taken quite a lot
of time but um but i did love playing
her and i did love working with these
wonderful actors and amy helps though
doesn't it and emmy helps and emmy helps
you get over and get better and feel
better awards really help
they definitely help
they help you get over yourself
they help you feel good it's great for
the kids
yeah it absolutely helps you're right
i'm a glass half-full kind of girl so
i'm gonna say you didn't say no we may
get more mayor but what i want to know
is what's the drink of choice tonight
what's the party like tonight ned my
husband wants tequila he keeps saying oh
we need tequila
tequila it's tequila
naked
naked nitro that's his brothers call him
nitro and the naked part you'll just
have to kind of figure that out okay
come on making nitrogen naked
it's tequila and pink grapefruit juice
just so you know with a little floating
jalapeno up here nick get in here
don't put him on tv
oh my god that would be hilarious
no
um so what am i going to be drinking i
think probably like vodka tonic i do
love vodka tonic i do but in america you
make them so strong that i have to like
mix it with a bit of soda you deserve a
strong drink tonight baby you carry all
the drinks you want yeah all the drinks
deal with naked nitro you need a strong
drink like i want like chips and you
know i want like i want like that cheese
whiz i'm like nah you know if someone
gave me a huge tub of the cheese balls
on the count of the of the spray cheese
i would be in there i would be so happy
y'all hear this somebody get this for
kate with naked nitro get the cheese we
got you baby we got you okay
congratulations so much
[Music]